HISTORY OF CHILD NEGLECT OR EVEN
REGISTERED SEX OFFENDERS.
HERE WITH MARK, WISCONSIN
SENATOR RON JOHNSON WHO IS ON
THE COMMITTEE THAT PUT OUT THAT
REPORT.
SENATOR, I CAN'T HELP BUT
REMEMBER THE POLITICAL HYSTERIA
THAT WAS HOW UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS WERE HUMBLED UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
NOW BECAUSE OF THIS CRISIS,
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
ADULTS ARE NOT VETTED ENOUGH TO
KNOW WHAT THEIR CRIMINAL HISTORY
MIGHT BE YET THEY GET
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS?
>> THEY ARE NOT BEING VETTED.
THEY'VE ISSUED A COUPLE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT HAVE
RELAXED THE TYPES OF CHECKS THAT
YOU DO ON THE PEOPLE,
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN ARE BEING
REALLY -- RELEASED TWO.
300,000 UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
SINCE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TOOK OFFICE.
225,000 BEEN RELEASED TO
SPONSORS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO THEY ARE.
WE DON'T TRACK THEM.
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD HIS
CRISIS, 2,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
TRUMP HAD IN ONE MONTH OVER
4,000 TODAY.
UNDER THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IT'S OVER 7,000 PEOPLE A DAY.
THEY DON'T CALL IT APPREHENSION
ANYMORE.
THEY CALL ENCOUNTERS.
WE ARE PROBABLY TALKING, AS YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT, 4 MILLION
PEOPLE SO FAR HAVE BEEN
ENCOUNTERED, PROCESSED,
DISPERSED OR COME TO THIS
COUNTRY IS A KNOWN OR UNKNOWN
GOT-AWAYS.
22 STATES HAVE A POPULATION LESS
THAN 4 MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS IS COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION APPARENTLY
COULDN'T CARE LESS.
THEY DON'T CALL IT A PROBLEM.
THEY CALL IT A CHALLENGE AT
MOST.
>> Pete: WHAT IS THE "WHY?"
TO ME ALWAYS THE MOST REVEALING
QUESTION.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ CRYING
ABOUT KIDS IN CAGES BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS
INTENTIONALLY MAKING SURE NO
CHILD WAS RELEASED TO SOMEONE
WHO WASN'T ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
NOW IT'S TENS OF THOUSANDS.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT OFTEN
WITH NO BACKGROUND CHECKS.
IF THERE WAS YOUR CRISIS OR IF
IT WAS JUST HYSTERIA, WHAT IS
THE "WHY" FOR WHY THEY ARE DOING
IT NOW.
>> YOU HAVE TO ASK
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
YOU HAVE DEATH DEMOCRATS WHO
VOTE TO NOT COMPLETE THE WALL
WE'VE ALREADY PAID FOR.
ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT ARE LARGER
THAN THE POPULATION OF 22
STATES.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
THEY WANT TO BRING PEOPLE IN
THAT ARE GOING TO BE BEHOLDEN TO
THEM WHEN IT COMES THE NEXT
ELECTION, EVEN THOUGH THEY CAN'T
VOTE.
OF COURSE, THAT'S WHY THEY ARE
ALWAYS FOR MAIL AND BALLOTING AS
WELL WITHOUT VOTER I.D.
I THINK THEY'VE GOT A GAME PLAN
AND THEIR -- THEY ARE CARRYING
OUT THAT GAME PLAN.
>> Pete: IS THERE ANYTHING
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL CAN
DO?
THE SENATE REMAINS IN THE
MINORITY.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN SLIM
REPUBLICAN HANDS.
IF THERE'S ONE THING YOU COULD
DO THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
EFFECTUAL AT THIS POINT, WHAT
WOULD IT BE?
>> WE HAVE TO RAISE THE ISSUE.
I WAS CHAIRMAN OF HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE, WE HAD CLOSE
TO THREE DOZEN HEARINGS ON SOME
ASPECT OF THE BORDER WHEN THE
CRISIS WAS FAR SMALLER.
WE HAD WRITTEN A LETTER TO OUR
CHAIRMAN WHO COMPLETELY IS AND
INTERESTED.
THE MAJORITY HAS NO INTEREST
WHATSOEVER IN THIS CRISIS ON THE
BORDER BUT WE JUST NEED TO RAMP
UP PRESSURE, TRIED TO GET THEM
MAINSTREAM MEDIA PAYING
ATTENTION.
RIGHT NOW IT'S ALMOST JUST FOX
COVERING IT SO MOST AMERICANS
DON'T REALIZE A FULL-BLOWN
CRISIS OCCURRING AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> Pete: THEY SEEM TO BE
PAYING ATTENTION A LITTLE BIT
BUT IT'S ALWAYS WHAT WE NEED TO
SPEND MORE MONEY O